[Music]
on this wednesday night the cost of
living and its effect on your bottom
line
canada's inflation rate soars to a level
not seen in almost 20 years my grocery
bill has doubled maybe even tripled
the impact on food and fuel prices and
interest rates
healthcare workers ordered to get the
jab or lose their job we stand by the
policy multiplying fears of what the
vaccine mandate could trigger
recommendations for royal rest why the
95 year old monarch has cancelled a trip
promise in pigs a surgical first that
could one day help people waiting for
organ transplants and status update they
see that they need to evolve themselves
facebook's plan to rebrand and focus on
the metaverse
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with what many canadians
already recognize the cost of living is
climbing in this country the price of
everything from groceries to gasoline to
housing is going up and the inflation
rate is now the highest it's been in
nearly two decades it hit 4.4 percent in
september that's the biggest yearly
increase since 2003. in the last year
the price of food jumped 3.9 percent
housing costs rose 4.8 percent and gas
prices spiked nearly 33 percent a number
of factors are driving up costs and one
of the key questions is whether interest
rates will go up too and gaviola has
tonight's top story
it's a sound that can make your heart
race
and that anxiety is justified nearly
everything costs more right now and few
places make that as clear as the
checkout aisle i have six kids five are
boys so they eat a lot
and my grocery bill has doubled maybe
even tripled and that means we have
less disposable income to go out
canadian households are feeling the
financial pinch an angus read poll
released today shows nearly half of
respondents say they're struggling to
cover their grocery bill in fact 87
percent say the rising cost of living is
their biggest concern overshadowing
fears of losing income or being jobless
i think everybody just has to learn how
to budget and and we have to live with
it there's nothing that we can do but
buckle up
there's more to come you had temporary
factory closures you had higher input
costs as well as the general theme of
supply chain disruptions so all three
factors contributed to push up
food prices this inflation is likely
here to stay even though at the start of
the year economists painted it as
temporary it's been running hotter than
the bank of canada's target rate since
the spring and with global energy prices
on a tear you can expect higher prices
at the pumps and beyond until spring of
next year putting the bank of canada in
a bit of a bind the bank of canada is
going to talk like a hawk but walk like
a duff analysts say this could spur the
central bank to raise rates sooner
rather than later in 2022 perhaps in the
second half of next year because the
bank of canada is likely to move before
the united states central bank that
means a stronger canadian community
for households and many businesses
sitting on record savings built up
during the pandemic this gives them a
cushion and time to prepare it solely
creeps up on them that you know all of a
sudden wow i'm paying more money from my
dad or i'm paying more money for my
goods and as a result then you know they
have an epiphany or some sort of
revelation that wow i might have some
financial problem here but those
struggling financially especially
businesses could be pushed over the
brink and this comes just as key federal
supports are set to expire on saturday
donna and gaviola in toronto thanks
mps get back to business in ottawa in
one month and vaccinations for covet 19
will be mandatory for everyone including
visitors and journalists only those who
have a valid medical reason are exempt
prime minister justin trudeau is in
talks with the other federal party
leaders about the protocols for the next
session and our david aiken is keeping
an eye on all this david
yeah there's still a lot of issues to be
worked out but one rule is clear mps
must be vaccinated to sit in the house
or even to enter the buildings that
their parliament hill offices are in i
think there's a lot of relief that this
decision has been made for the
parliamentary precinct knowing that all
visitors all mps all staff on premise
are going to be uh vaccinated
is a huge sense of relief and i think
entirely appropriate given the public
health circumstances
now the conservatives hate this rule
they object to mandatory vaccines for
mps just as they objected to mandatory
vaccines for civil servants now the only
exception to this rule is you mentioned
those with a valid medical reason and
those few will have to be tested daily
before entering the comments still not
clear how this will be enforced the
parties are still working that out and
this rule does not apply to senators who
will figure out their own rules also
this rule that everyone entering any of
the house of commons buildings must be
vaccinated while it applies to all
political staff every civil servant all
contractors and yes every journalist
donna okay david uh so apart from
vaccines will it be business as usual or
mps required to be physically present in
the house
that too is still up for discussion now
liberals and new democrats believe that
the hybrid model where mps are
participating by video conference is
still a valuable one having developed
having spent millions of dollars to
develop these tools it makes sense to
continue to use those tools in an
appropriate way
but once again the conservatives have a
different view they are insisting it's
time to ditch the hybrid approach and
move completely to in-person proceedings
and they have the support of the block
quebecois on that but the majority rules
here and the liberals plus the ndp they
have enough votes to prevail donna okay
david aiken in ottawa thanks
mandatory vaccine policies are being put
in place in many places across canada
and running into some opponents in
alberta more than a hundred thousand
health care workers have less than two
weeks to get their shots the vast
majority already have but others are
holding out and face being put on unpaid
leave heather eurix west reports
since the beginning of the pandemic
shelby bay has been eager to lend a hand
the cochran alberta nurse works with the
red cross and has been deployed all over
canada she's now working at a covet
testing center close to home if me being
at the testing center can relieve one
less overtime call then you know then
that's a win bae is one of 13 red cross
health care workers on active duty in
alberta outside resources coming in to
help just as some workers within the
province are choosing to resign on
october 31st all alberta health services
employees will be required to have two
doses of the covet 19 vaccine and not
everyone is willing to comply ahs says
that out of more than 108 000 workers 92
percent have now submitted proof of
vaccination but there are 1200 employees
seeking an exemption to the vaccine
mandate either for medical or religious
reasons 61 workers have resigned because
of the policy including 31 clinical
staff we stand by the policy
and it will be fully implemented
this vaccine requirement is essential
to ensure the safety of our people
the patients
and vulnerable albertans last week with
concern mounting its mandatory policy
could lead to health care shortages
quebec pushed back its deadline in
manitoba there are 158 health workers on
unpaid leave for refusing the vaccine
and across the country legal challenges
to similar policies are before courts
and human rights commissions i think by
and large the mandates will stand and
that any successes we'll see will be
one-off situations in in particular
cases where
as i say an individual maybe doesn't get
a health exemption that they they should
have received of course the major test
will come as these deadlines pass and in
alberta and bc those deadlines are next
week heather yurix west global news
calgary
plans to vaccinate american children
aged 5 to 11 against covet 19 have been
laid out by the biden administration
there will be no mass inoculation sites
pediatricians will be enlisted to work
with parents and the vials and the
needles to administer doses will be
smaller than than those used for adults
it's anticipated u.s regulators will
approve the pfizer biontech vaccine for
use in children in the coming weeks
pending the cdc's decision will ship
about 15 million doses out nationwide uh
in those next few days
with millions more going out each and
every week to make sure that we're
matching the doses with where they're
most needed
fda advisors are set to meet with pfizer
next week the drug maker says clinical
trials show two doses of its vaccine
produce a robust antibody response in
children aged 5 to 11 who are given a
smaller dose than those over age twelve
today the agency also authorized the
mixing of vaccine doses for booster
shots for hundreds of thousands of
canadians it has now been more than
eight months since they got their two
doses of the covid19 vaccine their
immunity to the virus is now waning and
experts say it's time to focus on giving
booster shots to those aged 65 and older
jamie morocco explains why
benita silver is approaching her golden
years she's also asthmatic so she knows
every breath of fresh air shouldn't be
taken for granted it's really really
terrifying not to be able to inhale a
very real concern if she gets coveted
which is why she wants a third vaccine
to protect herself
there's been some really good studies
showing that a booster shot in these
populations in particular
will certainly you know give them better
protection
already the u.s has recommended third
doses for those over 65 and may soon
lower that eligibility to 40 plus
meantime in the uk boosters are now
being offered for those 50 and older but
here canadians over 64 are still waiting
the national advisory committee on
immunization it's going to make it be
making further recommendations
quite soon but public health officials
aren't saying when only the northwest
territories have opened up the option to
all residents 60 and older the problem
now is we have people who you know have
been vaccinated but don't may not really
know
that they may not be protected as well
as they thought they were researcher rod
russell says we only need to look to
places like israel to see there's a risk
in waiting to give additional doses to
older more vulnerable populations
six to seven months post second shot
there was
you know increased breakthrough
infection and in the mortality rate in
certain age groups too as of october 2nd
520 fully vaccinated canadians have died
russell says seniors especially those
with underlying conditions who were
vaccinated more than six months ago
should now act as if they haven't got
the shot at all
silver got her final jab in august you
get older your defenses run down so
any kind of
assistance is appreciated a boost she
says she's ready to take any time jamie
morocco global news toronto an unfolding
disaster in india
coming up the race to rescue people from
raging floodwaters plus why the queen
just canceled a trip and a top honor
to a fierce critic of russia's president
queen elizabeth was all smiles last
night as she hosted some of the most
influential business leaders in the
world at windsor castle but the global
investment summit will be her last
official public event for the next few
days the 95 year old is reluctantly
taking her doctor's advice and resting
she has canceled a two-day visit to
northern ireland this week buckingham
palace says it's not coveted related but
as crystal commansing explains there are
a few other details
the queen's london home is always a draw
visitor excitement however dampened
slightly with worry her majesty has been
instructed to rest she's got to be real
person sometimes and just relax she's
just not a national treasure she's a
world trader she's worldly
a treasure with a jam-packed calendar
palace officials say the queen is in
good spirits but disappointed at having
to cancel her trip to northern ireland
the 95 year old looked well tuesday
night as she hosted business leaders at
windsor castle
last week she visited the welsh
parliament with the use of a cane but
still looked strong the queen has been
incredibly busy and her schedule likely
won't ease up anytime soon 2022 is her
platinum jubilee year and there are all
kinds of events
to honor the fact that she will have
served the public of the commonwealth
for 70 years
you do think about it but
yeah no we wish your best in luck with
our help
the queen is quote reluctantly accepting
her doctor's advice for rest she
reportedly believes you are only as old
as you feel a line shared by her private
secretary in a letter to the uk's oldie
magazine
she declined their oldie of the year
award saying she didn't feel she met the
criteria
crystal commansing global news
london
the rising death toll from covet 19 in
russia has triggered a lockdown there
more than a thousand people have died of
the virus in the past day that's the
highest number since the pandemic began
president vladimir putin is ordering
most russians to stay home from work for
a week later this month that will keep
some people off the crowded transit
systems but restrictions around most
public venues are being left up to local
authorities vladimir putin's fiercest
rival is being honored by the european
union russian opposition leader alexei
navalny has been given the eu's top
human rights award navalny is in prison
in russia the 45 year old activist was
arrested in january after traveling
abroad for treatment he was poisoned
with a nerve agent president of the
european parliament says the award
recognizes navalny's immense bravery in
fighting the corruption of the putin
regime the eu is also renewing calls for
navalny's release
still ahead the groundbreaking medical
procedure involving a pig that could
change human lives
the indian air force is stepping in to
rescue villagers from the rising flood
waters ravaging the himalayan region and
neighboring nepal more than 300
millimeters of rain fell in just 24
hours in some places streets are swamped
with knee-deep water the extreme weather
has killed at least 150 people and many
others are still missing
there's an important surgical first in
organ transplants doctors in new york
were able to attach a kidney grown in a
genetically altered pig to a human and
then watch as it began to function
properly the procedure is raising hopes
for thousands of people waiting for a
donor organ but it's also raising
concerns as eric sorenson explains
it is a breakthrough that could change
lives while pushing the boundaries of
cross-species transplants the surgery
was performed on a patient already brain
dead the family consenting to the
experiment before she was taken off life
support the greatest medical hurdle in
transplanting a pig's kidney has always
been aggressive rejection by the human
immune system but from this pig came an
extraordinary kidney it was genetically
modified to take out the gene that could
trigger rejection the organ was then
grafted onto the veins of the leg of the
patient and observed for 54 hours
doctors watching for rejection instead
it worked producing primarily urine just
what a kidney is supposed to do so two
things
no evidence of this you know vigorous
early rejection
and the second thing the kidney function
well the
significance of
moving you know this into a human i
think can't be understated
in canada four million people have
kidney disease according to the kidney
foundation the need for organs every
year greater than the number of donors
last year more than four thousand
canadians were waiting for a transplant
heart lung liver or kidney 280 patients
died waiting for their transplant and of
the four thousand still waiting 78
percent needed kidneys but a medical
breakthrough can also raise ethical
questions some may object for religious
reasons others uncomfortable harvesting
organs from pigs even though millions of
pigs are already raised to feed humans
one of the considerations really is that
these
uh highly evolved animals they have the
capacity to feel pain and to suffer it's
not resolved by saying well we're eating
pigs every day because that begs the
question whether we should be eating
them every day doctors say the next step
would be transplant surgeries to extend
the lives of the living to improve
quality of life for a year or longer and
reduce the number who are waiting and
dying without a transplant at all eric
sorenson global news toronto
facebook's new chapter next the
company's ambitious plan to rebrand
facebook has faced a ton of criticism
for allowing hate and misinformation to
spread on the platform and profiting
from it and now its ceo is reported to
be on the verge of rebranding his
company mark zuckerberg has said the key
to facebook's future is something called
the metaverse if you don't know what
that is you are not alone here's jackson
proskow
facebook revolutionized the way we
connect the company's next big step
could be one that changes everything
about online they see the writing on the
wall they see that they need to evolve
themselves tech website the verge
reports facebook is getting ready to
rebrand with a new name and new focus
the company declined to comment to
global news the facebook site along with
instagram and whatsapp would be
platforms operated by a parent company
that's built around something bigger the
so-called metaverse what is the
metaverse so the metaverse is really the
successor to today's mobile internet you
have to think about it as the future of
what comes next expert kathy hackl
describes the metaverse as the next
generation online space that will blend
elements of our real world with a
virtual one so we're heading into this
convergence of physical and digital
lives facebook already owns oculus which
makes virtual reality goggles and
recently revealed workrooms for vr
meetings there users interact in a
digital meeting room as 3d avatars that
mimic their real-life movements think
zoom on steroids i always wanted to help
build this kind of immersive
system that you could be in with your
friends and feel like you were present
together but go explore the company
recently announced plans to hire 10 000
workers to build the metaverse but back
in the real world facebook by any name
faces serious problems facebook
consistently chose to prioritize its
profits
former employee francis haugen recently
blew the whistle on company policies she
claims amplified misinformation and
harmful content
governments around the world have
accused the social media giant of
abusing its monopoly a new name and new
product designed to help escape reality
won't make any of that disappear
jackson prosko global news washington
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
euro canada is cape spear newfoundland
and labrador the most easterly point in
north america we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you